why our perfumers is so [ __ ] stupid
the dialogue is always nonsense and it's
max two sentences and it'll be like a 60
second spot worse like Johnny Depp and
he's like inside outside it's everywhere
Saxon mosque and do that big you as this
[ __ ] what does that mean it's
everywhere it's amongst you it's in you
it's within you it's with Long Branch
whiskey lone Brent it's all around us
feel it in your soul you can hear it
like a pork cracklin it's even in your
Long Branch
it's your Sasuke it's your sex and my
second Musk you know yes I sex and must
could be like a sick country singer -
yeah Saxon Musk I bet you mr.
McConaughey knows a little bit of thing
about sex and mask sex and must we
behind two favorite things it's sex and
mother I can smell your Musk ever long
night of sex but that sex must call me
one of the best parts of the podcast was
there talking about they're talking
about this chip and it's it's you know
how it's gonna replace our need to speak
and all this stuff and Joe is like so
what how long is that
oh wait like how long are we away from
that from from not being able to need to
not being not having to speak anymore
yeah and Elon was like oh you know this
isn't gonna sneak up on you by any sorts
like it's years and years away from
being a reality and so and Joe's like
how how far though like just help just
say and how far how far do you think
anyone's like well probably five to ten
years Joe's like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's that that's probably definitely
sneaking up on us
the [ __ ] imagine in five years from now
dude
we're just dude our podcast is just this
we're just looking at the camera and
once every five minutes we go you have
to laugh yeah again bro that is my worst
nightmare that's gonna be terrible for
boyfriends you watch love island she's
gonna know your favorite one is what you
like you have to watch love island
looking at the ceiling it's like one of
those eye trackers that they have on
yeah people's dreams yeah map of where
you're looking that's gonna
revolutionize the way couples argue in
public that's gonna be great if you
[ __ ] just at dinner just [ __ ] know
you don't have the gesture you're just
[ __ ] screaming at each other
full volume [ __ ] me right here in the
rest are you gonna [ __ ] it and then one
of them eventually just looks at the
waiter goes yeah five years five years
but wait dude you even you even
fantasize about the best part of that
what in America when you're done with
your check you don't have to go find the
you have to wait for the waiter to come
around you just lean out look at him in
the kitchen and just go yeah
meanwhile the fine I want the freaking
check dude what are the first versions
like super hard to say like even the
simplest [ __ ] the beta I can't what I'm
not you have to poo just go why is it in
Mandarin that guy hello
it's in Spanish now I had what do you
want me to do what are you saying dude
are you drunk are you drunk again are
you damn bro
speaking of chips oh we back on this it
might be coming though what do you mean
chip daddy what I mean some University
developed like a thing that's like an
adhesive it's supposed to track the
symptoms of kovat mom which is cool but
I'd like it's something that tracks my
thoughts and feelings and aspirations
something that cares about me yeah if
it's Ilan's chip whoo
then I'm cool with it yeah get old for
sure
Oh ilan chip you want can chip me
anywhere dude what I mean we're joking
about like we're talking about like chip
me chip me daddy and all this yeah but
if Ilan's chip can cure my shitty like
speech impediments and stuff like that
then I'm down you know he was like yeah
yeah it'll naturally just make you
smarter because you'll you'll cuz we're
talking about like symbiotic
relationships with AI mm-hmm and Joe is
like that scares me and he's like no we
kind of are already we already are like
when you leave without your phone you
feel like a part of you is missing
mm-hmm the only difference now is like
the data transfer is really slow between
the phone in your brain because you got
to look look things up with your fingers
or whatever here we go that here we go
you just be smart and in which case if I
can be smarter I'm first in line for
that chip baby chip me up daddy yeah
yeah I kind of like that never being
dumb at a party got a nice just yeah
just like you're like the shitty
know-it-all
yeah actually [ __ ] everyone becomes a
yes actually guy because there's a chip
dating is [ __ ] impossible because
everyone is just constantly actually
according to the the
no that's gonna be some classes [ __ ]
only the people that can afford it are
gonna turn into hooking serious
[ __ ] yo yeah if I can i phone first
came out it's gonna be like some guy who
wears a business suit but he got
business shorts because it's hot yeah
and he pulls up in his 3:30 2050 BMW and
he's just correcting you at the cash
register about some [ __ ] you said yeah
let's take your [ __ ] groceries man you
know they don't call them groceries in
Malaysia I know that because I have the
chip like [ __ ] you man and there's gonna
be the group of the group of like the
hacker group that that old jailbreak the
first version so you can you know runs
and everything yeah they've run sex in
your head automatic sex dreams wet
dreams on command these are in the
terminal executing [ __ ] command line
scripts yeah prompt oblige and run oh it
worked
dude they fall asleep next to terminal
they live like they lie down and it's
open and they just hit like a scripted
like you know set timeout initiate yeah
now we wait That moment when you pop it
edible and you you shell script your wet
dream
you be like I said this dream but I want
to do like a [ __ ] 30-second sketch
words a guy sitting in his living room
he's like hey Alexa turn on my air
conditioning and then like a long 15
seconds goes then his wife just walks
out of the bedroom she's like he's like
thank you it's like there's no robot at
all he's just his wife it's just his
wife's name is good hey Alexa what's for
dinner
spaghetti Tom spaghetti plate September
by Earth Wind & Fire
what's that it [ __ ] ukelele now
playing ukulele rendition of Earth Wind
and Fire
you